[Applause]
and with that 2024 was off to a colorful
start down under in Australia more than
1 million people rang in the New Year in
Sydney Harbor taking in a display of 13
and 1 12,000
[Applause]
fireworks
a few hours later in Hong Kong 12
minutes of fireworks and music dazzled
above Victoria Harbor the longest and
largest display it's ever
produced a spectacular show in Taiwan 2
as the Clock Struck
[Music]
midnight fireworks sparkled over the
Thai Capital
Bangkok more than 15,000 and pyrot
Technics lit up the world's tallest
building in
Dubai and in Qatar fireworks lasers and
drones soar over the city of
lucel soon the celebrations moved to
Europe where tens of thousands of people
filled the French capital's famous
Shamel and fireworks lit up the up
[Music]
Triumph in end of your speeches many
world leaders called for
peace let us continue to pray for the
people suffering from Wars the Ukrainian
people martyred the Palestinian and
Israeli peoples the Sudanese people and
many
others London welcomed 2024 with its
biggest ever fireworks
display celebrations then moved to the
Americas as Brazil welcomed the Year
with fireworks over the Copa Cabana
Beach in Rio de
Janeiro and new New York hosted its
Party On Time Square with the iconic bul
drop there were messages of unity and
reminders that despite the challenges
and ongoing conflicts so many people
face at least one thing is shared by all
the hope of the new year and even more
better days to come Mal
alaz make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer